we thought it would be fun to spend a
few minutes just a few minutes um Brian
Greene and I having a little
conversation about mostly about the
science behind what was happening in his
life and all these moments the world
here's Brian Greene come come let's
let's bring our chairs a little closer
together the interesting thing to me was
he was searching all through his life
for simplicity he couldn't have had a
more chaotic personal life and he was
looking for things to pull together in
the universe and I mean you could I
guess you could do armchair
psychoanalysis and say he needed to find
that because he couldn't find it in life
but what was the who was the unified
field theory he was working on I mean
the the formula at the end were the
numbers and and symbols that he that we
saw on the screen literally was what he
wrote in a notebook just before he fell
asleep for the last time he was writing
trying to figure out a theory that would
unify all the forces that he was aware
of right up until the last minute what
what is a unified field theory well I
think he described it really well I mean
the goal of physics the goal of science
is to find the deep patterns in nature
and the deepest of patterns you imagine
will be able to describe the broadest
spectrum of phenomenon so he desperately
wanted to find a single framework that
would put gravity the force of gravity
that he understood well from the general
theory of relativity wanted to meld that
with the other force that he was well
aware of which was the electromagnetic
force
so the goal was to put those two forces
together and showed that they're
basically the same thing described by
the same method
Oh structure so at that time were they
the two forces that he was aware of
gravity in Electra meant so that means
gravity in and light and all the other
electricity magnetism light gravity
wanted to put all together now the thing
is even at that time he didn't pay that
much attention to it it was known it was
becoming known that there are other
forces so there's the nuclear force the
strong nuclear force it all danced
against that some of that happened
during his lifetime right what did that
bother him did he think oh I got more
forces I have to put together you would
think so but um but no but you know I
think the general belief and we'd have
to like check with Walter Isaacson's
book right but I think the general
belief is he didn't pay that much
attention to these other forces and we
can even go further there the thing that
he was really leaving out a deep sense
was quantum physics quantum mechanics
even though he wrote the first paper on
quantum mechanics oh one of those 1905
papers was on the photoelectric effect
that's the paper for which he won the
Nobel Prize not the relativity papers
and that's the paper that ultimately
yields quantum mechanics but sort of
like giving birth to an unruly child you
don't like how they grow up he got
completely turned off by quantum eyes
quantum mechanics he viewed as the wrong
way of describing nature and he thought
the unified theory would do an end run
around quantum mechanics so all this
stuff that he didn't like he would say
that was just a temporary resting place
the unified theory would make quantum
mechanics unnecessary how did quantum
mechanics come out of the photoelectric
abut what is the photoelectric effect
yeah so the photoelectric effect is the
recognition that light itself which had
been described as a wave from the time
of Maxwell an electromagnetic wave could
actually be described in terms of little
tiny particles that light was actually
made up of what we call quanta photons
and that move recognizing this deep
relationship between a wave-like
phenomenon and a particle-like
phenomenon ultimately by the mid-20
and by the 30s gives rise to quantum
mechanics so did he
quantum mechanics as I understand it
sort of acknowledges that it's the light
and other electromagnetic waves are both
waves and particles probably because
probably is the language of quantum yeah
that that is what it is so so quantum
mechanics basically shows that whereas
Newton and everybody before quantum
physics including Einstein said what
physics is about is tell me how things
are now and I'll use my equations to
predict how they will be in five minutes
or an hour from now if they're here now
then they'll do things and that'll
happen in this and then you can know
exactly where it'll be later that's
right in quantum mechanics comes along
and says that's the wrong way of
thinking about things it says the best
you can ever do in any experiment is
predict the probability the likelihood
of getting one outcome or another you
cannot say the electron will be here in
five minutes you can say there's a 42
percent chance it will be there and a 36
percent chance it will be over there and
so on and that's the best you can do and
this way of thinking about nature even
though it was borne out by experiment
just didn't sit well with Einstein well
he didn't actually talk about
probabilities did he and oh yeah he did
no he really kicked off quantum
mechanical he had to embrace quantum
mechanics because it was doing such a
fantastic job of explaining data but he
basically wanted to take a sledgehammer
to it and smash it to pieces and by 1935
one of his other important papers was
basically trying to prove mathematically
the quantum mechanics could not be the
full story because it predicted such
things that couldn't possibly be true to
any rational thinking person like what
like what you do over here having an
effect on something over there
quantum entanglement but by 1980
certainly by today we know that
entanglement is real so this crazy
feature of quantum mechanics that he
tried to use against the theory itself
is actually borne out by data today
and they're from them from that last
paragraph you just spoke came those
those two famous sayings of his about
entanglement he said that spooky action
at a distance spook and used the word
spook that's what the German word for
spooky is so the other one of that is
objection his objection to quantum
mechanics being that God doesn't play
dice with the universe yes
and that wasn't lovable excite of things
but that if everything is a probability
and nothing is that definite then it
really goes against the idea that things
can be set and solid why did he stick to
that was it was he was stuck in an old
paradigm was it emotional was it
philosophical why couldn't he go where
the numbers led him well I think he was
a revolutionary in some ways and in
other ways he wasn't in other ways he
was really very tied to a philosophical
perspective on reality and he had
achieved great things as a young man I
mean think about it he just sat there
with his pen and his paper and it worked
out space and time and special
relativity had worked out gravity and
general relativity this kind of
achievement just reinforced that that
was the way to understand nature this
completely classical perspective with no
quantum mechanics insight then all of a
sudden these other people come along and
say that's the wrong way of thinking
about nature that's a tough thing too
but that's not I was tired
I ain't no I wouldn't say so no he i
would decide that he was tired he was
just so married to a particular
perspective on the world and it was an
unshakable belief in the coherence of a
classical perspective and i think that
was something he just could not give up
it's interesting when you talk about how
he was sitting there doing it with a
pencil and paper and his imagination
again that that other saying that's
often attributed to him that imagination
is more important than knowledge it's
hard to believe that he would say that
except he accomplished so much with his
imagination based on the knowledge he
had and in the piece tonight he talks
about that moment when he imagined a man
falling off a building happiest thought
of his life he is thought of his life
why why was that the happiest thought
because that sounds like he's saying
it's the most central image to all his
thinking yeah that was the key idea that
propelled him toward the general theory
of relativity see gravity is a difficult
subject it's hard to even figure out a
way in to a description of the force of
gravity at the level that Einstein was
searching for what he realized was that
a certain kind of motion freely falling
motion in essence counteracts gravity
can eliminate gravity which means in any
situation where there's gravity if you
don't want to have to deal with it
directly just execute a certain kind of
motion jump out a window and then
gravity goes away what
you jump out the window gravity makes a
quick entrance actually it actually
doesn't it doesn't so you jump out the
window what actually happens from
Einsteins perspective is that the ground
is just rushing up and hitting you
you're not being pulled down by gravity
from Einsteins perspective I mean when
Newton was sitting there under the tree
according to Einstein it was not that
the apple fell on his head his head
rushed up and hit the Apple and that's
on Stein's view now I can show you this
thing
yeah I'm right okay you can cure brink
you bring my little water thingy out
there whoever may be backstage listen to
us right here we go
so so this idea of of getting rid of
gravity by going into freely falling
motion can be illustrated by a little
experiment so I'm gonna do it cuz I
don't want you to get all wet so so what
I'm gonna do is let me describe it first
when I take off this cap air pressure is
going to be entering into the bottle and
water is gonna spew out a few holes that
I have here because gravity is gonna
pull down on the water and then what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna let the bottle go
into freefall and watch that the water
won't spray out any longer right so
that's what you should look for okay
here we go
all right right so here goes to water oh
sorry about that right so um now watch
when I let it go holy moly
right one more time gravity goes away
right yeah there it is all right
now okay that's a great trick yeah this
can Keeney's die can you explain why we
just saw what we saw
yeah so as the bottle is in freefall it
no longer feels the force of gravity
right I mean another way of thinking
about it that maybe is even you know
more visceral than this little
demonstration is if you are standing on
a scale right you look down you see
whatever you know 150 160 pounds for me
something like that right if I jump out
of the window with a scale at my feet
and I look down on it what does the
reading go to it goes to zero because
the scale and me we are moving together
so in that sense I'm no longer pushing
on the scale I'm no longer experiencing
gravity as I did when I'm standing here
in the stage so if you can counter
gravity if you can cancel it out by
going into this motion
Ayten really the reverse was also true
you could mock up gravity you could
simulate gravity by accelerating too so
that's where you get to a car turning
exactly and you still you feel them you
know it's no longer what you feel in an
elevator which is nothing yes and even
though you and the elevator were falling
that's right if you cut the cable of an
elevator then indeed you and the
elevator will fall together just like
the water and the bottle fall together
just like the scale and my feet fall
together you don't feel anything the
exact reverse of that is now take an
elevator in empty space no gravity empty
space and pull up on the cable making
the elevator accelerate in that
direction if you're in that elevator you
will now feel your feet pressing against
the floor because the floor is pushing
up against you you will have simulated
gravity why is that important
Einstein understands motion really well
but he doesn't understand gravity now he
has reduced gravity to motion
accelerated motion that gives him a way
in and it does take him a good eight
years to fill in all the details but
that yields the general theory of
relativity Einstein didn't understand
gravity very well he didn't in 1907
1915 he
makes this idea and parlays it into a
single equation that describes the force
of gravity in a way that had never been
achieved so 1915 was different from 1905
because in 1905 he had a very special
sense of what gravitation was no he
ignored gravity 1900 I was just really
Tibbets racial rates only took into
account motion that was not speeding up
not slowing down no accelerated motion
right when he includes accelerated
motion
all of a sudden gravity comes into the
story for free in the manner that we're
just describing because accelerated
motion makes gravity makes it all of a
sudden appear even though it wasn't
there necessarily to begin with and
that's the window into the general
theory of relativity ok ok the quiz
you have been a wonderful audience and
it's been really fun to be with you
tonight share this evening and thanks so
much thank you Brian for help
smarty
you